what's up better reject nation I'm Greg
a la John Humphrey we're gonna watch
from looper spider-man three details
revealed wow wow wow wow wow to find out
what we got here before we go into this
I wanted to say thank you to everyone
who helped us have a successful in
October at our patreon page we do weekly
Q&A is over there and we also do TV show
reactions stream along sync up with a
timecode and those shows are agents of
shield the stranger things season three
Gotham just made a season for hunting a
hill house Season one Cobra Kai season
two and then there are shows where we
have the stream along option but we also
have the option where we edit reaction
highlights so you don't have to worry
about that at all footage included and
those shows are supernatural it's just
made the season for hunter hunter one
punch man Code Geass Death Note
my hero academia just minutes the season
for movie as well
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood and
attack on tied and he does music video
coverage weekly let's swing into this
spy date Sony and Disney found their way
back to the bargaining table and a deal
has been struck o webhead will get at
least one more MCU set starring vehicle
one that we have a funny feeling will
have the word home somewhere in its
title these are just a few things you
can expect details about spider-man's
third solo outing in the MCU are
exceedingly slim surprisingly though
where we know the film was released
there as it was announced the same time
that Marvel and Sony went public with
the renewing of their shared custody
deal spider-man's next web slinging
adventure will hit the big screen on
July 16th 2021 market at the moment it's
possible that could be pushed off to a
later date for a couple of reasons first
Marvel's 2021 slate is already pretty
crowded previously announced to be on
top for that year a shang-chi and The
Legend of the ten grains on February 12
dr. strange in the multiverse of madness
on May 7th and Thor love and thunder on
November 5th
if Spidey 320 States holds up or MCU
NASA leaves for MTU pictures in the same
year fans might see its crowding the
market yes is need Plus outputs will see
the release of another highly
anticipated superhero film Matt Reeves
the Batman which hit screens on June 20
Robert Pattinson starring click will be
the first Batman so they've all a marble
a decade Marvel's sure confident in the
web sling disability to kill it at the
box office there would be no shame in
rethinking putting him up against the
Dark Knight see you spider-man flick
have not been divulged it all likelihood
because the movie is still tangled up in
early development we do know one thing
however life is about to get even more
difficult for Peter Parker spider-man
far from home ended on a heck of a
cliffhanger click Parker's identity
having been revealed to the public
thanks to Mysterio and Jay jonah Jameson
in the MCU where Jameson is apparently a
conspiracy theorist vlogger and not a
newspaper man but he still looks a heck
of a lot like JK Simmons
who else we can speculate outside of the
third Tom Hollands movie Sony is
continuing to develop at Spidey related
properties independently of involvement
from Marvel Studios at the moment of
those projects include venom to Morbius
and Kraven the hunter spider-verse was
just announced stay right there and
equalize the series scribe Richard wink
it should be noted that since the days
of the aborted Andrew Garfield starring
amazing spider-man franchise Sony has
been keen to get the sinister six a
revolving team of old Webb heads
greatest nemesis onto the screen she
gets the sinister six before they appear
as standalone villains Wheeling's and
dealings that have gone on in recent
months fans could be forgiven for being
a bit confused as to the nature of Sony
and Marvel's relationship at this point
follow us here venom which starts on
hardy and featured exactly no references
to spider-man surprised everyone by
grossing over 850 million dollars
worldwide
despite lukewarm reviews Morbius the
living vampire and longtime Spidey
nemesis which Sony had on top for 2020
may very well follow suit venom or some
Morbius fastball s only universe of
Marvel characters everyone knows that
the MCU reigns supreme so why not
engineer a crossover between the two
universes in fact this may very well be
what's happening and if so spider-man 3
will likely be a focal point of the
strategy no less an authority the Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin Feige has
teased that Spidey is quote the only
hero with the super power to cross
cinematic universes and in the past
he suggested that Hardy's venom and
Holland Spidey could one day meet on the
big screen it's all but certain that the
two studios are busy hashing out the
details even as you're watching this but
for now we'll just have to wait and see
how it all plays out what if spider-man
far from homes biggest twist came during
the flicks post-credit scene when it was
revealed that the Nick Fury Maria Hill
would seem for the entirety of the film
were in fact scrolling postures assigned
to Parker by the real fury who was busy
well in space tending to some secret
mission
on a ship full of squirrels all of this
won't being extremely shoeless jokes
aside this sets up a massive wave of
speculation of the flicker bin task of
doing a bit of heavy lifting in setting
up an MCU adaptation of The Secret
Invasion storyline in which frozen
portrayed the highest ranks of power on
earth by way of you know imitating
everyone remarks made by director John
watt seem to indicate though that the
twist was actually his decision and not
a mandate from on high this would likely
mean that fury space Jones isn't in fact
setting up major future developments for
the MCU as a whole
Oh kids have been teasing it what was it
it's completely unknown but our money is
on the superspy returning to earth to
resume its stewardship of Parker with a
few interesting stories to tell when
Sony and Marvel made er but the first
question and fans Minds was the obvious
one for how long all we know for certain
is that a psycho misled solo venture
Spidey will appear in at least one more
Marvel Studios film beyond that's the
future is a question mark considering
that the MCU and Sony's universe of
Marvel characters are finally making
overtures toward recognizing each
other's existence though there are a few
waves is likely to go estudios good as
previously mentioned find a viable
narrative for the characters a switch
cinematic universes or as dead liner
suggests they could form a loose
connection with a kind of
call-and-response aesthetic which would
keep the franchise's largely separate
what's an gently connected or if the two
Studios can truly see their way clear to
giving the fans what they want a two
universes submerge with series
characters being absorbed into the MCU
it seems like a pretty slight
possibility and it might be but it also
appears to be the option likely to
generate the maximum amount of box
office dollars so we're going to go
ahead and call it not impossible
check out one of the players Kevin Fagan
clip+
even more looper videos about your
favorite comic book movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
spider-man 3 plot details revealed and
then a little bit in the video the plot
details are pretty slim there are no
plot here you go this is some pretty
interesting stuff to riff on as the plot
of spider-man's contractual woes
honestly they pop a great point with the
first thing the spider-man 3 is gonna be
1 out of 4 Marvel slated films now
Marvel has pushed their films before and
you know moved around the slots however
you can with an infinity war they change
it like a month before to a week earlier
not as big of a deal but they cause a
lot of other studios to go we gotta move
our movies a week now because three can
fit anymore is gonna snow overshadow us
I do think that's a bit much especially
cuz the Disney plus series seemed
integral to the whole MCU experience now
and keeping up with the whole timeline
if you got a Disney Plus thing going on
and then you have four MCU movies coming
out so close to each other that's a bit
much it's a little too much like three
is plenty I guess you could argue one
MCU movie per season but still she's
already like yeah we're getting to the
point in culture where if you want to
you could just only watch superhero
entertainment because there's enough of
it and there's going to be enough of it
especially in 20 20 21 you're gonna have
interconnected TV and interconnected
movies plus you're gonna have DC and
whichever other comic book studios are
putting out movies you've got like spawn
and then bloodshot on the horizon so
you've got more people entering the
arena twenty Tony one especially I mean
that's a whole year removed so I wonder
how we're gonna feel by that time I mean
I'm sure we'll miss Spider Man by that
time I doubt we'll be super-hearing out
but will we be super here doubt no I
don't think we'll be superhero out
highly doubt that I just think for MCU
films is a lot specifically MCU to me
it's not really the idea of too many
comic book movies in a year it's just
for connected movies in one year that's
a big deal
the thing about how John Watts said that
it was his idea with the scrolls Nick
Fury and Maria Hill it might not be some
set up for something and honestly that
would be
annoying to me because I just go what
was the point of it it wasn't funny it
doesn't make the rewatch that much more
impactful or like oh [ __ ] there were
scrolling selector canal literally
doesn't this move is it do anything to
enhance the story or make the
storytelling more compelling honestly it
doesn't me I thought it was cool as an
effective like oh what stink fury doing
in space water the scrolls helping out
ion and to me I'm like it's kind of I
would be annoyed if there's like no real
plans for it yeah and I would be really
surprised if they dropped that just
because it's such a significant context
piece that it would feel very careless
to me coming from the MCU to drop an
anvil like that and then to just
completely ignore it into the future and
with all their talk of going even
further down the cosmic realm I feel
like it makes sense I mean to me if
that's true if this was just a John
Watson oh yeah I almost feel like maybe
it just worked with their plans already
and then they were like oh yeah okay
well we can throw in a little extra
scene to two inputs at the future or
something like I would believe that more
than just it's some random thing that's
never gonna come back yeah yeah that's
true
that would just seem negligent I mean
I'm really what I hope to though is that
for spider-man 3 that they really use J
John Jameson that would be so rewarding
the most exciting thing to me is like
having JK Simmons back yeah I mean with
JK Simmons that some people thought it
was kind of distracting that it didn't
put him in any makeup but I think to
distinguish the universes and whatever
you know whatever semantics or
technicalities you want yeah are you
about it just makes it easier to even
there's even the exact same robot 6 1 7
James but it does also allude to I mean
I'm still hoping one day Sony will pull
the trigger and get a crossover with
Garfield Holland and Tobey Maguire I was
empowered or I still hope it
specifically that's gonna be there
spider-man 3 you guys wait and see and
also we're gonna speculate about it
forever at will Tom Hall and every go to
Sony like the Morbius or venom world
or will venom or Morbius ever go into
the MCU world I personally would much
rather Tom Holland crossed over into
this Sony verse as opposed to these
characters going into the MCU that's
five that works better much rather
prefer that yeah because the Sony verse
has something of its own vibe yeah like
the x-men are gonna have to get
recontextualized and I feel like I think
I think if I put anything in the MCU or
you're gonna have to essentially reboot
it yeah whereas I think you against kind
of make some mumbo-jumbo Joe um and I
feel like that can almost work in a
sense thatis wages some of the
complaints about like oh the past couple
spider-man movies have been really heavy
on other MCU stuff so if he went over to
a Sony and just did spider-man's stuff
and it's not so good you know people
might actually appreciate that too and
that actually might be a way to get a
little more spider bang for your spider
buck you know I wonder what into the
spider-verse part two is gonna do if
you're gonna connecting any of these
things or having a venom appear or
something sex would into the spider
versity I want to talk about this really
quick I'm not excited about it because
they have changed riders and they have
changed the directors which is shocking
that they would do that they want an
Oscar man they want an Oscar and
everyone thinks it's like the Phil Lord
and Chris Miller movie and while their
touches all over that film it was
directed by three people that were not
Phil Lord and Chris Miller and then they
got different directors to step in and
they got a different screenwriter to
come in why would they do that that's a
great question
provided that they wanted to come back
or whatever yes when the visual style
and the pacing and everything was so it
a girl do you know like why would you
just get some different bad huh we'll
say that's just my little tidbit about
that the thing that always really
intrigues me about these continuing
spider-man debates is actually the
sinister six stuff because that's an
idea that seems like it doesn't want to
die but has already like actively failed
via at least one franchise well I think
you gotta have a few villains
established in stand-alones and
then cross them over I feel like they
keep trying to rush to get there do a
reverse Avengers if anything do you like
a bunch of solo movies and then finally
in like the seventh one all six of them
team up and yeah that's horrible first
my group yeah yeah yeah that would be a
good call anyway guys what are your
spider-man 3 hopes comment below how did
you like those plot details you guys can
subscribe to looper subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
really gonna know if I went over got a
video up and I'd like to end this with a
patient add a shout out to Luke Anderson
I got nothing to say to you nothing
disappointed Luke you can con for like
almost a year are you you ever talk to
me do you even realize how much of a
major contribution you've been our
patreon page I like to give personal
shout outs but I have literally like I
have like no words perfectly sure doing
a year look what you're doing to our
fearless leader
he's crumbling Luke II needs your love
frightened frightened leader frightened
are frightened leader because he's Col
not put a fake image in the absence of
your love and attention this needy man
needs you Luke where are you I mean yes
and fearless leader fearless but also
fearful in this moment we can work with
that we can work with that it's an
asterisk you know everyone is you got a
little there being a part of our patreon
page thanks for being beautiful